die werbung ist heute die treibende
kraft hinter unserem digitalen leben
ohne werbung kein facebook oder kein
google
das weiß auch david die fremde internet
pionier der ersten stunde
da darf feiern interessierte ihn nie bis
er die gemeinsamkeiten zwischen damals
und heute erkannt hat
die data bewegung nutzte die form der
werbung um sich zu verkaufen oder
fälschte sie sogar was wir vorschlagen
ist sie installieren auf ihrem
internetbrowser eine erweiterung ihre
online werbung ersetzt durch da der
kunstwerke oder das lorenz zusammen mit
co autorin anita hugi hat die fran die
web doku data entwickelt
als erstes installiert man sich einen
werbeblocker mit dem kleinen hugo ball
icon tauscht man die werbung mit kunst
aus es soll natürlich ihr leben
angenehmer machen und gleichzeitig
denken wir über die frage der digitalen
werbung nach
die heute das trojanische pferd der
spionage ist im guten alten darin wird
hier mit kleinen subtilen mitteln gegen
die werbung und somit gegen die ständige
überwachung gekämpft ich bin ein großer
verfechter der gratiskultur belgrad dann
richtig nicht das scheinbar kostenlose
dass dir dein guthaben dann verlaufen wo
du kommst wohin du gehst absaugt
denn das macht die werbung auf der
zeitungsseite von lemonde etwa das bis
zu 60 virtuelle spitzen die dich
ausspionieren
also wenn das kostenlos ist
dann ist der preis den wir dafür
bezahlen viel zu hoch
ein online projekt mit einer klaren
aussage und mit verschiedenen aktionen
die dazu aufrufen die digitalen mittel
selber in die hand zu nehmen und nicht
nur passiv zu konsumieren
so kann man unter dem hashtag da da da
tat will's schreiben die dann in einer
kakophonie von texten zu einer
soundcollage werden
ein gedichte street von heute ist wie
ein laut gedicht von damals
für mich ist es eine engagierte
webdokumentation es ist eine art und
weise den leuten zu sagen wir haben
zugang zu einem ausserordentlichen werk
zurück ein werkzeug der kreation und der
distribution nicht nur der konsumation
und wir müssen all dies unbedingt wieder
zurückerobern sowie da da während des
krieges den öffentlichen raum
zurückerobert und so greift adata auch
von der realen welt ins netz ein
mit dem handy kann man eine da
marionette steuern die je länger sie
herum wandert desto mehr daten von einem
sammelt die marionette wird zur
persönlichen daten spur
ein spiel und ein ironischer kommentar
zu einem nicht ganz freien internet data
hat keinen einfluss aufs internet
das wäre lächerlich alles was wir machen
ist lachen sie lachen um nachzudenken